[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est une légende du football
49 sélections en équipe de France
vainqueur de l'Euro en 84 demi-finaliste
du Mondial en 82 en 86 il a marqué plus
que des buts il a marqué une époque les
années 70 et 80 il a marqué l'histoire
d'un club Laas Saint-Étienne par ses
prouesses physiques et techniques par
ses dribles inoubliables par ses passes
décisives exceptionnelles mais fait plus
rare il a marqué les Français par son
calme par son élégance et je dirais même
son humilité son altruisme certains
disent qu'il n'a pas été assez perso et
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas été de ces
joueurs individualistes qui cherche à
briller seul sur un terrain ou à écraser
les autres pour se faire remarquer par
les grands clubs toutes ces qualités lui
ont valu le surnom d'ange vert elle lui
valent encore aujourd'hui une place à
part dans le cœur des Français
d'ailleurs il se confient à eux dans un
livre foot sentimental ils leur disent
ce qu'ils pensent du foot pro du foot
amateur des travers de l'époque de la
violence de certains supporters mais
alors lui qui a fait preuve de temp de
classe que penseent-t-il de nos bleus
aujourd'hui de nos joueurs en général y
a-t-il encore de l'élégance dans nos
équipes de foot y a-t-il d'autres anges
posons-lui toutes ses questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue à vous Dominique rochetau et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ici au Sénat au dome Tournon est-ce que
vous avez l'impression d'avoir un digne
successeur aujourd'hui il y a-t-il un
autre ange dans le football il y a des
joueurs que j'aime beaucoup actuellement
il y en a en particulier bon peut-être
pas qui aurait peut-être pas le
qualificatif d'ange mais enfin non moi
j'ai toujours bien aimé Messi voilà
quand je suis quand il est arrivé à
Paris j'étais j'étais vraiment très
content parce que j'ai pu le voir
j'avais jamais vu jouer eu dans un stade
et donc voilà c'est c'est
c'est un beau joueur puis sa
personnalité son son côté quand même je
dis quand même parce que maintenant il
est il est il est dans une autre sphère
je dirais mais il a une certaine
humilité aussi moi j'ai bien aimé le
personnage parce que dans votre carrière
et c'est l'une de vos grandes fierté je
crois vous n'avez pris que deux cartons
jaunes hein c'est bien ça oui c'est ça
ça ça semble rare aujourd'hui voir
impossible inexistant il y a quelque
chose qui a changé oui bah ça fait
partie aussi de de mon
euh ma quelque part de ma fierté c'est
c'est j'en suis aussi fier que que ma
que que que ma carrière parce que bah
c'est signe de d'un comportement sur le
terrain et puis c'est pas un hasard
parce que c'est ce que je raconte aussi
dans dans mon livre euh j'ai mon mon
premier exemple mon premier entraîneur
mon c'était mon père et je l'ai vu je
l'ai vu jouer je l'ai vu évoluer et ça a
été mon comment dire votre mentor oui
voilà c'est parlera parce que vous en
parlez effectivement dans ce livre mais
qu'est-ce que vous ça vous inspire vous
de voir des joueurs qui discutent les
décisions des arbitres en permanence sur
un terrain de foot est-ce que il y a
quelque chose qui vous horpile dans
cette attitude vous qui avez été si
différent sur des terrains oui ben il
enfin moi mais il y a pas il y a pas que
moi y en a d'autres d'autres qui se sont
bien comportés je P je pense un joueur
d'ailleurs on parlait des cartons Gary
Lineker qui est un qui était un grand
joueur anglais qui a eu zéro carton donc
voilàétais battu mais non euh ce que
j'en pense bah oui oui ça ça ça ça moi
je trouve ça
complètement quand quand je vois des
joueurs qui vont discuter au près de
l'arbitre qui qui discuteent toutes les
euh toutes les les décisions c'est c'est
systématique hein ouais je comprends pas
parce que c'est là où je je fais aussi
dans dans dans mon livre la comparaison
avec le rugby parce que c'est un sport
que que j'ai toujours aimé que j'ai
pratiqué un petit peu quand j'étais
jeune ouais et le rugby c'est vrai qu'il
y a des règles qui font que Ben le les
les joueurs ne peuvent pas discuter les
décisions auprès de l'arbitre pourquoi
on le fait pas dans le football ça bah
c'est ce que je c'est ce que je je me
demande c'est ce que je j'aimerais qu'
qu'on le fasse il y a une règle qui fait
que quand un joueur va discuter auprès
de l'arbitre mis à part le
capitaine l'arbitre a le droit de
d'avancer le la faute à à plus de 10 m
donc ça sanctionne l'équipe et au foot
on pourrait très bien le faire mais je
sais pas pourquoi on le fait pas on est
toujours un petit peu en retard au
niveau de la des règles de la FIFA enfin
bon ouais je vous entendais parler de
votre salaire lorsque vous étiez joueur
ça semble assez fou aujourd'hui quand on
voit ces chiffres votre premier salaire
à Saint-Étienne c'était 800 francs par
mois donc l'équivalent de 120 €
aujourd'hui dernier salaire en 1989 à
Toulouse je crois après être passé par
le PSG 120 130000 francs encore en franc
oui moins de 20000 € aujourd'hui
l'argent a tout gâché a tout gâché
j'irais pas jusque là mais l'argent a
changé les choses bien sûr changé l'état
d'esprit bah il y a ne serait-ce que le
déjà le milieu des agents quoi le c'est
la le milieu le milieu des agents fait
la plie bout temp dans le ENF notamment
dans le football mais dans le sport
aussi en général euh il y a beaucoup
d'argent qui tourne dans ce milieu-là et
ça aussi par exemple maintenant un jeune
de de 14 15 ans a tout de suite son
agent donc ça moi je trouve ça
complètement fou quoi et et puis il y a
pas de réglementation malheureusement
ils ont essayé de réglementer le ce
métier mais il y a pas de réglementation
ce métier d'agent parce que moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai je peux en parler parce que
j'ai j'ai épousé un peu ce ce métier
pendant 2 ou 3 ans et j'ai rapidement vu
que c'était pas fait pour moi et parce
que je justement parce que c'est bah
jeis une certain philosophie c'était
c'était surtout pour aider les joueurs
pour les conseiller conseiller sur un
plan aussi
carrière mais souvent bah la majorité
des agents sont là aussi pour pour
gagner beaucoup d'argent parce que ils
savent que y a des possibilités quoi
c'est un vrai sujet pour vous hein parce
que en introduction de votre livre vous
citez Bob Marley euh notamment avec
cette phrase ne gagne pas le monde en
perdant ton âme la sagesse vaut mieux
que l'argent ou l'or ça c'est un vrai
message que vous adressé euh au monde du
foot au footballurs aussi message que
j'aime bien plusaux instances ah bah au
footballeur aussi c'est ça à tous les
jeunes aussi surtout parce que mon livre
il est adressé à la fois bon à ma
génération bien sûr mais mais aussi aux
jeunes j'ai envie de j'ai envie de de
transmettre des choses que voilà et
euh avec une certaine une certain
humilité aussi quand même je je je
détiens pas forcément la vérité mais bon
j'ai envie de transmettre des choses aux
jeunes aussi leur donner quelques pistes
quelques axes on voit aussi que les
footballeurs deviennent un peu des
leaders d'opinion pour les jeunes
aujourd'hui c'était peut-être un peu
moins le cas à votre époque je pense
aujourd'hui la société les politiques
attendent de des propos responsables des
prises de position un peu sur tous les
sujets y compris sociétaux est-ce que
c'est pas trop est-ce qu'on leur demande
pas trop aussi aux
footballeurs plus que ouais mais quand
on a une personnalité c'est sûr que Ben
les micros viennent vite donc on est
obligé moi j'en ai subi les les
conséquences aussi quand j'étais jeune
bon j'avais j'avais envie aussi de de de
de
m'exprimer une prise de j'avais des
prises de conscience notamment en argent
quand on est allé en Argentine pour la
Coupe du Monde ouais enfin plusieurs
plusieurs événements mais je me suis
très vite aperçu que bah après il
fallait faire quand même attention à ce
qu'on disait parce que c'était vite
repris c'était vite donc
euh serait que vous êtes content de pas
être footballur aujourd'hui non on on on
on demande au footballeurs de de d'avoir
des opinions fortes sur des sujets ouais
mais après c'est après il y a les
réseaux sociaux aussi ça va très vite
c'est pour ça moi ça n'existait pas ça
réseaux sociaux Twitter et tout bon
benah l'image de Mbappé qui que oui bah
si quand il tweet c'est sûr qu'il estès
il est lu il est écouté c'est sûr et ça
ça peut ça peut aller loin il y a un
euro de foot qui arrive ça n échapper à
personne comment vous voyez arriver
cette compétition que vous vous avez
gagné est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'on a des chances P qu'on a les bons
joueurs aujourd'hui pour aller loin dans
cette compétition vous avez alors
sincèrement je pense qu'on a jamais eu
une aussi bonne équipe de France bah
c'est pas par hasard on était on a été
champion du monde là en 2018 en 2022 on
est allé en finale on trait bien plus
aussi encore être champion du monde
et là bon on sera on sera parmi les non
seulement parmi les favoris mais je
dirais presque les les favoris qu'est-ce
qui vous fait dire qu'on a jamais eu une
équipe aussi bonne d'après vous bah
parce que c'est une équipe qui a qui a
d'excellents joueurs qui voilà a une
génération assez fabuleuse quoi grâce à
la formation française grâce à la
formation française qui est notamment
une des meilleures au monde mais ça je
euh ENF j'en parle aussi dans dans dans
mon livre euh il y a la formation
française la formation dans les centres
dans les centres de formation dans les
club pro mais il y a aussi mais il faut
pas oublier le le le football de la base
les football des des
oua et là il y a le F qui se creuse
entre ce football et il y il a un
football à deux vitesses quoi fa quire C
de football votre parcours à vous je le
disais vous le racontez dans foot
sentimental un joli titre qui vous est
venu assez naturellement qui rend
hommage à vos deux passions le football
et la musique pour ceux qui l'ignorent
le foot c'est quand même une affaire de
famille hein vous l'avez dit ça vous
vient notamment de votre père pour qui
vous aviez une une admiration sans
bornes vous écrivez à son propos j'étais
très fier de mon père ce héros qui m'a
fait aimer le football et m'en a appris
les bases vous expliquez aussi que votre
calme apparent sur les terrains malgré
les nombreuses provocations c'est en
pensant à votre père que vous l'avez
tenu ce calme et pourtant vous écrivez
si je paraissais calme à l'extérieur je
bouillonnais à l'intérieur qu'est-ce qui
vous faisait bouillir comme ça ah ben
mon caractère mon caractère qui faisait
que il
fa je pense que céit important pour moi
de justement de de de faire du sport et
puis euh euh d'avoir une certaine
puisavoir de après il faut faut faut
regarder les choses faut regarder moi
j'ai eu des j'ai rencontré des gens qui
m'ont qui m'ont justement amené dans
dans ce sens-là amené à avoir une
certaine un certain recul un certain une
certaine façon de voir les choses euh et
je me suis vraiment vite orienté alors
c'était dans les années 70 c'était vers
cette cette philosophie de de non
violence j'en parle aussi dans dans le
dans mon livre parce que qui qui dit
violence ben dit enfin la violence amène
la violence toute façon et traumatisme
aussi il y a une bagare qui vous a
traumatisé avec votre meilleur
AMAG visage s le ne c ça é un déclic ça
éé un déclic vous vous j'ai rencontré
aussi plein de gens
tiiré David Douillet qui sont des jeux
d'ocage moi j'aime bien ce ce sport
parce que c'est un sport qui qui qui
apprend la la maîtrise de soi et ça
c'est ça m'a beaucoup apporté aussi h la
violence dans le monde du foot se passe
aussi beaucoup disons-le hein du côté
des supporters aujourd'hui elle peut
être verbal les crit raciste les champs
homophobes et puis physiquees on a vu
l'entraîneur de l'OL Fabio grossseo le
visage en sang après le le cillassage du
bus avant une rencontre avec l'OM au
Stade Vélodrome une rencontre finalement
reportée elle vient d'où cette violence
comment vous l'expliquez vous celle du
côté des supporter j'explique que le
football de toute façon é un sport
leement le sport le plus populaire au
monde donc il touche ben il est à
l'image de la société et c'est vrai que
alors de la violence il y en a toujours
eu he moi même dans dans le football
j'en ai connu dans les stad il y a eu
des des comment
dire je parle le houiganisme le match la
finale de Coupe d'Europe entre Liverpool
et la Juventus où il y avait eu beaucoup
de morts enfin bon nous ça nous est
arrivé aussi ces dernières années quand
j'étais dirigeant au club de
Saint-Étienne quand on allait dans
certains certains endroits bah on était
C assé on avait le car caayassé donc
c'est pas une première et c'est vrai que
bah il faut il faut vraiment être hyper
sévère pour par rapport à ces c'est
suppor mais c'est marrant que vous
disiez ça parce que dans votre Liv vous
dites ce n'est pas avec le bâton que les
choses s'arrangeront vous êtes plutôt
une politique trop sécuritaire vis-à-vis
des supporters et dans les stades
justement non moi jeis plus pour
l'aspect éducation
pédagogieque en amont sur sur la
communication c'est pour ça que je dis
faut faut aussi responsabiliser les
support peut-être aussi qu'il soi dans
les instants du football alors qu'ils
sont les supporters c'est des c'est des
gens qui viennent sur les stades bah
c'est des qui viennent payer le leur
place et puis voilà quoi c'est mais
c'est pas uniquement ça les supporters
ils s'investissent dans leur club c'est
c'est l'histoire du club
aussi des supporters qui sont sont
fabuleux quoi qui qui qui se qui font
tous les déplacements enfin qui c'est
c'est leur vie donc c'est c'est c'est
cux c'est c'est pour moif ENF j'aime
bien les rencontrer d'ailleurs c'est ce
livre j'ai fait un peu pour ça pour les
rencontrer quand quand jeisend pour le
rendre hommage mais il y a aussi des
individus qui sont pas là pour qui sont
pas des supporters du tout qui sont pas
là pour pour pour les pour les bonnes
les bonnes raisons je reprends le fil de
votre histoire qui s'écrit très vite
avec Saint-Étienne dès 1971 en tant que
stagiaire votre notoriété grimpe
rapidement le public aime vos manières
votre élégance votre mobilité vous êtes
recruté en équipe de France et c'est le
sélectionneur Stéphane Kovax qui vous
repère et qui vous dit à l'issue d'un
match on se voit en sélection un petit
c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé c'est
vraiment comme ça que ça s'est passé
ouais ouais c'est ça comme ça cétait un
match de début de saison euh et puis
j'avais vraiment c'était mes premiers
matchs avec Saint-Étienne et euh donc je
jouais dans une équipe déjà où il y
avait enfin c'était la meilleure équipe
française il y avait des des joueurs des
joueurs internationaux et puis à la fin
du match bah il était venu voir les
joueurs en fait et puis moi il me
connaissait pas je pense mais bon il
m'avait vu jouer sur sur ce match tap
j'ava marqué de buts oui voilà et puis
dans les vestiard il m'a dit voilà il m'
il m'a croisé il m'a dit bon ben bientôt
enfin voilà ouais ça pourrait plus
arriver ça une chose pareille i on est
quand même quand on élabore une équipe
enfin j'imagine quand on est
sélectionneur de foot c'est c'est c'est
tout un plan tout un travail c'est
élaborer une équipe c'est pas comme ça
sur un coup de cœur enfin ça se fait
plus si peut-être aussi mais il a il y a
aussi il y a le côté proximité euh je
dirais euh alors il y a le le
sélectionneur bon euh un sélectionneur
comme ça bah qui qui rentre dans les
vestiè comme ça après un match je pense
ça seit ça se fait de moins en moins euh
c'est comme les médias les médias bon
nous moi à mon époque les médias
aussitôt après le match ils étaient déjà
dans le vestière nous on sortait de la
douche on nous tender les micros euh il
y avait le côté proximité moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai gardé plein d'amis de journalistes
et etant toute ma toute ma carrière
après ma carrière maintenant c'est les
conférences de presse et c'est c'est ce
que je reproche un petit peu mais bon
c'est comme ça c'est l'évolution oui on
a mis des distanceces bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr les conférences de presse
devant 100 personnes bon ben euh ça
j'aurais pas j'aurais pas trop aimé quoi
ouais c'est une position difficile
d'être sélectionné ou non sélectionné
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
difficile de devoir bah toujours faire
ses preuves pour que le sélectionneur de
l'équipe de France fasse appel à vous et
vous et vous recrute en équipe de France
en
sélection alors moi sincèrement je je
pensais pas du tout à tout ça mais
j'étais vraiment peut-être un peu naïf
un
peu c'estàd que moi je moi ce qui
m'apporté c'était de je alors j'ai
peut-être aussi été éduqué comme ça et
puis il y a quand je suis arrivé à
Saint-Étienne
moi mon pour moi la philosophie du
football c'était de de marquer des buts
enfin il y avait il y avit pas cette
aspect aspect collectif et c'est ce que
m'a apporté Saint-Étienne l'aspect
collectif la solidarité enfin certaines
certaines valeurs et il y avit pas de
plan de carrière quoi non pas pas du
tout plan de carrière moi à la fin de de
quand je quand je pars de
Saint-Étienne du PSG j'ai j'ai joué 7
ans au PSG
et j'avais marqué 100 buts mais et quand
je suis parti de du PSG je savais pas du
tout que j'avais marqué 100 buts quoi
pour moi c'était pas c pas la
priorité suis beaucoup bien après j'ai
une archive à vous proposer Dominique
rochetau c'est une un document délivré
par nos partenaires sur cette émission
les Archives nationales c'est une photo
qui devrait vous rappeler des souvenirs
finale de Coupe de France entre le PSG
et Saint-Étienne au Parc des Princes 15
mai 82 un vendredi soir un match
incroyable après avoir été menés les
vers égalisent puis repassent devant
Paris grâce à un doublé de Michel
Platini et en toute fin de prolongation
vous Dominique rochetau permettez à
Paris de disputer la séance de tir au
but et c'est finalement le PSG qui gagne
elle a pas d être simple cette soirée le
premier titre du PSG ouais le premier
titre du PSG oh bah simple simple moi
après j'étais du côté du PSG quoi
j'avais le maillot du PSG je défendais
mon maillot fois j'étais sur
terrain avant le match bon le fait de
rencontrer Saint-Étienne c'est sûr mais
bon après moi c'était c'était la
première finale de la Coupe de France
avec le PSG le PSG commençait à voir
justement parce que le PSG à l'époque
c'était on venait au PSG comme si on
venait au théâtre on venait voir le un
match de foot quoiis et là c'était le
début vraiment des des des supporters
les supporters des fidèles supporters du
PSG qui qui étaient présent d'accord ah
une question en vous pas une seule envie
moi je me suis même demandé si dans ces
moments-l on n pas envie d'être moins
bon que d'habitude tellement on n' pas
envie de marquer contre contre contre
l'équipe qu'on aime contre son équipe de
cœur non jamais non c'est pas du tout ça
non non non une fois qu'on est sur le
terrain après on on joue pour son équipe
quoi c'est c'est c'est normal mais par
contre moi c'est vrai que on l'a après
ma carrière les Stéphano l'ont souvent
reproché mais gentiment gentiment mais
mont souvent reproché ce ce fameux but
qui a qui a fait que que saintétien pas
gagné a pas gagné ce ce match en plus
c'était le dernier match de Michel
Platini voilà mais c'est votre club de
cœur quand même c'est une ville à
laquelle vous tenez Saint-Étienne c'est
ah ben complètement c'est mon club c'est
mon club mais j'ai deux clubs hein en
j'ai j'en tris parce que j'ai j'ai fin
ma carrière à Toulouse aussi les trois
clubs c'est des clubs que que je suis
toujours mais le club qui m'a marqué
vraiment bien sûr je suis arrivé à 15
ans à Saint-Étienne j'ai fait toute ma
toute ma formation et
puis c fameuse épopée avec les la finale
de la Coupe d'Europe enfin bon ça ça ça
marque bien sûr d'ailleurs ça ça marque
tellement qu'on qu'on se retrouve
toujours chaque année notre génération
on se revoit toujours 40 ans après donc
c'est pas par hasard quoi le le PSG
aujourd'hui que vous inspire-t-il sur le
plan sportif je vous pose la question
parce que je me suis demandé si vous
pensiez au club parisien lorsque vous
avez écrit ceci à l'image d'une société
éclatée le football a suivi une
évolution qui l'éloigne peu à peu de sa
dimension collective il est devenu une
addition voire une jute apposition de
destins individuels qui ne favorisent
pas l'expression commune d'une équipe
est-ce que vous penseer au PSG quand ça
va un petit peu loin je pense c'est vous
qui le dites ou oui non mais je va un
petit peu loin mais c'est un peu ça
quand même même parce que quelque part
moi pour moi le le football c'est ça
c'est avant tout un une aventure
collective quoi c'est c'est moi c'est
c'est c'est là où j'ai connu mes
meilleurs moments quand on a quand on
gagnait des des des des matchs ou quand
on les gagnait pas aussi à Séville par
exemple quand on perd contre l'Allemagne
bah c'était une inventure collective
avant tout c'était pas euh donc et là ce
qui me gêne un peu c'est que mais al
c'est peut-être aussi un peu la faute du
enfin de la Société des médias tout ça
qui font que on on attache beaucoup
d'importance maintenant alors au
résultat bien sûrou au prouess d'un seul
ouais au prouess d'un seul mais au
comment dire au au stat les stat le
meilleur buteur le meilleur passeur le
meilleur donc les joueurs ont tendance à
aller vers ça et et ça enlève un peu de
justement de
le tout le côté collectif du du sport du
football quoi mais est-ce que c'est pas
ça qui manque au PSG parce que beaucoup
s'interrogent sur le fait que le PSG
soit bon en Ligue 1 mais au niveau
européen n'arrive pas à décoller est-ce
que c'est parce que c'est cette fameuse
addition Ju ta position de de prouesse
individuelle mais que finalement il
manque un esprit collectif à cette
équipe ou à d'autres de manière générale
oui oui oui bien sûr c'est il y a des
clubs qui réussissent mieux que d'autres
parce que justement il y a l'esprit
collectif et l'esprit continuité
c'est-à-dire que maintenant aussi mais
je veux pas critiquer je veux pas dire
toujours que c'était je veux pas faire
le vieux con que c'était mieux avant que
c'était c'est mieux c'est mieux avant
mais les les clubs qui qui travaillent
sur la continuité pendant plusieurs
années avec le même entraîneur avec les
mêmes joueurs bah ils obtiennent plus de
résultat que les que les clubs qui
changent d'entraîneur chaque année et ça
c'est une évidence et c'est vrai que le
PSG dans dans les dans les dans les
dernières années ils ont eu tendance à
en parce qu' parce qu'ils avaient mis la
barutete parce qu'il fallait des
résultats parce qu'il fallait gagner la
Coupe d'Europe et dès qu'il y avait pas
pas le résultat ben on changea
l'entraîneur c'est l'entraîneur souvent
qui qui est le fusible donc et ça c'est
pas forcément la meilleure des choses
c'est peut-être lié à ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs dans dans le foot
professionnel mais vous rendez vraiment
hommage dans dans votre livre à ce foot
amateur dont vous parlez aussi depuis le
début de cette interview vous dites
c'est le football à l'état pure les
enfants jouent s'amusent se divertissent
sans aucune arrièrepensé est-ce que dans
le foot de haut niveau on a un peu perdu
ça de vue est-ce qu'on s'amuse plus on
ne fait plus ça pour s'amuser se
divertir avec la pureté et la légèreté
j'espère qu'il s'amuse toujours moi je
pense que les grands joueurs Mbappé je
je pense je vois évoluer sur un terrain
il s'amuse c'est sûr maisess si il s'est
amusé pendant toute sa carrière c'est
sûr mais c'est pas parce que c'est des
grands joueurs qui s'amusent plus euh
par contre ce qui me gêne un peu aussi
maintenant c'est que B il y a tellement
d'argent dans le football il y a un club
de foot une équipe de foot c'est 30
joueurs 35 joueurs maintenant et il y a
des joueurs qui jouent plus pratiquement
pendant toute la saison qui jouent très
peu et parfois alors moi je sais pas
enfin il me semble que si je jouais pas
dans un club je demanderai à partir ou
mais il y a des joueurs bah ça Satis
faait il continuent il restent dans dans
leur club parce que parce que voilà ils
sont bien dans ce club ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent et et c'est ça c'est
le côté un peu gênant
quoi j'ai des photos à vous proposer
Dominique rochetau c'est un rituel dans
cette émission première photo que je
voudrais vous montrer je sais pas si
vous la connaissez il s'agit de Monica
sttab c'est une ancienne footballeuse
allemande aujourd'hui entraîneuse voilà
de la sélection féminine saoudienne et
elle aimerait que l'Arabie Saoudite la
Coupe du Monde féminine en 2035 d'autant
plus que le pays est déjà candidat pour
le Mondial masculin en 2034 vous qui
avez exprimé des rétissence au fait de
participer à la Coupe du monde en
Argentine en 78 et vous l'avez un peu
évoqué tout à l'heure dans cette
interview notamment pour dénoncer la
jeinte militaire au pouvoir un peu seul
à l'époque d'ailleurs pour le faire
est-ce que vous diriez qu'on peut jouer
dans n'importe quel pays et dans
n'importe quel contexte ou est-ce que
quand même on a une responsabilité on
doit faire attention les pays dans
lesquels on va jouer ou entraîner comme
comme monicachttab
mais c'est l' l'image du football actuel
quoi voilà c'est c'est l'argent qui
prime faut dire faut dire les choses
comme elles sont quand je vois qu'il y a
une coupe du monde qui va être organisée
sur trois continents euh le je crois que
c'est en 2000 2030 enfin bon ouis avec
un bilan carbone qu'on critique déjà
d'ailleur beaucoup d'avions là c'est
c'est uniquement les intérêts les
intérêts financiers qui qui qui prime
donc je pense qu'il y a des endroits où
on pourrait justement accueillir des une
coupe du monde une coupe du monde c'est
fabuleux pour un pays d'accueillir une
coupe du monde mais des endroits des euh
qui qui ont pas eu qui ont pas forcément
les les la possibilités les moyens et on
le fait pas j'ai une deuxième photo à
vous proposer il s'agit d'Éric Cantona
ancien footballeur lui-même devenu
acteur maintenant chanteur il a sorti un
disque organisé une tournée c'est même
un tournoi dans sa carrière je vous en
parle parce que vous êtes vous-même je
l'ai dit un passionné de musique et puis
vous avez été acteur dans un film je le
rappelle pour ceux qui l'auraient oublié
un film quand même de Maurice piala en
95 où le Garçu vous partagez l'affiche
avec Gérard de pardieu quantona parle
d'un besoin vital de s'exprimer est-ce
que vous aussi vous l'avez ce besoin
vital est-ce que vous reconnaissez un
petit peu dans la carrière qu'il a mené
parce qu'il a fini par transformmer
l'essaiis en devenant vraiment acteur et
même je je je suis assez assez
admirative admiratif je sais pas si le
mot mais bon je trouve ça très très
courageux de sa part de de faire ce
qu'il fait parce que c'est pas évident
mais bon il touche un peu à tout
pourquoi pas bon c'est je su un artiste
dans l'âme je pense
et moif enfin sur un plan
musical c'est pas c'est pas pour
critiquer mais j'aime tellement la
musique je je la place tellement haut
que je je n'irai pas dans ce domaine là
le cinéma ça m'a plu parce que c'était
une petite un aparté quoi un aparté une
petite aventure en plus Maurice fala que
que je que j'aimais beaucoup et donc
j'ai eu cette chance là et de voilà et
vous citez Obama en intro de de ce livre
livre toujours si j'ai décidé de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
c'est que j'ai compris que je ne
pourrais jamais être Bruce Springsteen
c'est parce que vous saviez que vous ne
pourriez pas être BR springing que vous
avez fait du foot oui bien sûr vous
aussi je pas V faire de musique une
dernière photo c'est le tour de France
parcours officiel le parcours officiel
de la 111e édition a été
dévoilé par Christian prudom le patron
du Tour qu'on a reçu aussi dans cette
émission votre père vous l'a fait
découvrir en allant à la rencontre des
coureurs le tour qui traverse plusieurs
pays maintenant plus seulement dans
l'Hexagone c'est quelque chose que vous
voyez d'un regard critique ou
bienveillant ah plutôt critique c'est
vrai oui oui parce que ça reste le Tour
de France je sais pas moi je sais pas
ENF bon ben bien sûr pourquoi pas faire
une étape mais là par exemple ça c'est
pareil c'est c'est c'est trop c'est trop
quoi euh le prochain Tour de France va y
avoir quatre étapes en Italie bah qure
étapes pour un tour de France quatre
étapes en Italie quoi pour bon euh non
trop c'est trop
ah ben c'est dit c'est clair j'ai une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
le lieu dans lequel nous nous trouvons
Dominique rochetau nous sommes entourés
de quatre statues qui représente chacune
une vertu il y a la sagesse la prudence
la justice et l'éloquence est-ce qu'il y
a une de ces vertus qui vous parle
particulièrement qui vous caractérise
peut-être vous toutes toutes en pas
l'éloquence pas l'éloquence d'accord non
je pas j'admire les G les gens mais vous
vous sentez sage vous vous sentez S
ouais mais je suis pas non plus je suis
pas pour vraiment l'extrême sagesse
j'aime pas les les gens trop sages bon
et ben c'est dit merci merci infiniment
Dominique rochau de vous être prêté à
l'exercice de cette interview de cet
entretien si particulier merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous au Sénat et merci
de nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine
émission à retrouver en podcast
n'oubliez pas à très bientôt sur public
SCA
[Musique]
merci